Quick reminder guys check the description for a link to our self-made seminar!
It's a three day hands-on training event where we are going to teach you how to make a living making videos at home
Hey guys. I'm Nate welcome back to the lab today
We've got a very fun experiment where we see what happens if we put liquid propane into liquid, nitrogen
now liquid propane usually will freeze at
306 degrees Fahrenheit below zero
liquid nitrogen is about
321 degrees Fahrenheit below zero so it should in theory be cold enough to freeze our propane into a solid
I want to see what happens and I bet you do too in a previous video
We showed you a little hack for how to get propane out of your canister in a liquid form rather than a gas
We're going to be using that hack to partially fill a water bottle and then lowering that water bottle into our liquid nitrogen to see
If we can actually get our propane to solidify as a part of this experiment
I have this mixture of propane and butane in this can it's usually used as a camp stove fuel we're gonna try the same thing
Putting some of this into a bottle and then freezing it and see what happens especially if it'll light on fire now
I don't want to fill the house with the fumes of propane and butane and I also don't want everything to light on fire in
here
So we're gonna move this outside
Our first step is gonna be to pour off some of our liquid propane into our water bottle
So I'll just turn the nozzle upside down put it in the bottle and then open it up as far as it'll go
See after a couple seconds of cooling down it starts just dripping out
Snow, it's very strongly propane
Propane usually boils and turns to a gas at about 45 degrees below zero and that's pretty cold
But it's not nearly as cold as liquid, nitrogen
All right you go. We can see that
We've got liquid propane about two this first line in the water bottle
hard to see through just because it is pretty cold and a lot of frost starts forming on the outside of it, but
See how much we've got so now. We've got a very cold liquid in the bottle
Let's take our very cold liquid and put it in an extremely cold liquid
Here goes I
Think I can probably just kind of let it sit there the propane will be dense enough
To submerge a little bit into the liquid, nitrogen
But the air on top of the propane of course is much less dense, so it just sort of hold itself floating
With the propane under the liquid nitrogen and the rest of the bottle above it
I can see some vapors forming inside the bottle. I don't know for sure what that is
I assume it's condensed propane, but it could be water condensing on the inside of the bottle as well in the form of water vapor
It's only been a few seconds, but let's check nope still liquid
But I keep going water freezes at about 32 degrees Fahrenheit propane freezing below
300 degrees below zero so it has to get really really cold before it starts to solidify
Little liquid it almost has to get down to the temperature of the liquid, nitrogen
Help insulate the bottle so it really keeps all of the cold in and to help keep some of our liquid nitrogen from dissipating
I'm just can take some paper towel
Push it in the sides just to maybe save ourselves from losing a little bit of liquid, nitrogen
Can't tell for sure but it does look like there is something going on in there, so I'll pull it out really quickly
Let's look at what's happening. Oh, man
I think I ruined it by pulling it out it started like clouding up a ton in the liquid it looked like it
Maybe had a little bit of freezing just starting to go
and I
Should just let it go
Definitely see something happening in there little bits moving around
I think we're actually getting a little bit of freezing on the surface of the propane
well our propane in the bottle has now been sitting in this nitrogen for quite a while probably at least half an hour and I
Think we might have gotten a little bit of a slush, but it's certainly not frozen solid. It's possible
I would just need to leave it in for much longer
You know ice in a freezer takes up to three hours to freeze some times
So it's possible that I would need to do the same thing with the propane
Because I'm not that patient I'm gonna try taking it out now and see what happens if I just pour it out
I'm hoping we have a little bit of a slush thing going on
It's hard to tell while it's still in the container either way after I pour it out. I'm gonna light it on fire
Here's our bottle
and that still looks
Pretty runny. It does look like it's somehow separated like there's another layer I
wonder if liquid oxygen has formed on top of the propane or something doesn't really look the right color but
There's more liquid in here than when I started
So it has to have come from somewhere
Let's pour it out and see what happens
Whoo the bottle got too cold all right
It is a beautifully dense white smoke and
It looks like we've got liquid propane
very very cold liquid propane
This may be very dumb. I'm going to try and light it on fire
Maybe not so dumb. Well. It's on fire the wind is kicking up a little bit getting more air in there
About what I thought would happen the propane just dissipates so quickly
Well, and now it's gone
once you pour it out it just
disappears almost entirely and immediately
Well that didn't work very well
I was really hoping for some frozen propane, but I'm not sure how long that would take to really get to a solid chunk, so
Now I'm going to try pouring a little bit of liquid nitrogen into a cup and then pouring some of our propane
Into the liquid nitrogen there's no bottle in the way
You've got a couple seconds to cool down and then it should start dripping
All right, there's a nitrogen with the propane
That is about the thickest densest white smoke, I've ever seen come out from here. It's not smoke vapor
Wow
Definitely was not expecting that
Wow okay something about the propane and the liquid, nitrogen
Made it pop. I don't know what did that?
There's just sort of a bubble of propane floating on the surface of the nitrogen
Huh lighting it up with a laser. You can see a little propane blob
floating on the liquid, nitrogen
And I am amazed that is not started to solidify
Just it is just in liquid nitrogen. It's touching the liquid nitrogen, but it's doing really nothing, and if anyone's curious
No the laser is not actually affecting the movement it moves exactly the same way with or without the laser beam on it
Doesn't run away from the laser doesn't run to the laser
All right, I do still have the butane and propane mixture and butane freezes at only
220 degrees Fahrenheit below zero so it's possible that the mixture will freeze in the liquid nitrogen better than the straight propane dip
Let's find out
And this nozzle is great that went way faster than the propane one
Okay, propane butane mixture lower this down into our liquid, nitrogen which has
lowered itself quite a bit down
Used up a fair amount of liquid, nitrogen or let's experiment
We've got some sort of vapor climbing up out of the bottle not really sure what that is could be
Condensed air it could be the propane in butane
While I've been waiting, it's gotten a little colder out here, so you'll notice
I'm now wearing a jacket
But I think we've made good progress our butane propane mixture seems to have started to solidify on the inside of our water bottle
I'm not sure if it's a slushy consistency
Or a solid one my plan as well take the water bottle out
Cut it open just above where it's frozen, and then either try and pop it all out if it's solid
And if it's not solid then I'll try and scoop it out with this popsicle stick and then either way
I'm gonna light it on fire
There you go, okay, it's still very easy to squish so I doubt it's frozen completely solid
Yeah, look at that. It's like propane butane soup
Some kind. That's that's a weird. Oh, it's melting. It's melting
That stuff melted
Almost instantly once that stuff wasn't surrounded by liquid nitrogen anymore. It started melting immediately how fast
Got on my hands just a little bit
Didn't melt the glove
Definitely no injury from it
And now it's gone. Just just warmth really startling warmth not dangerous warmth
To be clear a little piece of bottle I tossed it through the flames and it still had propane and butane
Residue all over it so it caught on fire and then just shrunk down
We just have the very bottom of the bottle now. There's actually even still some
Frozen stuff in there. I don't know if that's propane and butane I think that it might just be ice
I think there was a little bit of water residue inside the bottle because it's not
Evaporating all that fast or melting as fast as the propane and butane did so pretty just just ice
There you go our experiment was to see if we could freeze
propane and while I think we might have had to get a little bit slushy after sitting in our liquid nitrogen in a bottle for
About 30 to 40 minutes it definitely never got solid, and if it was slushy
It immediately turned back to a liquid after it was poured out the propane and butane mixture did work considerably better
I think that's because the butane has a higher freezing temperature so the two mixed we were able to get a very dense
Slush, I think it might have even turned solid eventually if we had just left it in for longer
it's also possible though that the butane was freezing and the propane was not and we wouldn't have really achieved a solid block unless we've
Left it in there for hours, if at all either way once we scoop that thick paste out. It immediately started melting soon
We just had a puddle of a mixture of butane and propane in our little pot that was fun to light on fire
But it wasn't really anything spectacular
Overall I would say that butane and propane are best left in liquid or gaseous form they're much more useful that way
Freezing them is very difficult, and it doesn't get any sort of flash burning the way that gasoline does when you're freezing liquid, nitrogen
Thanks for joining us for this video today and remember to come grab some hats shirts or other merch at the king of random calm
Sea there
It looks alive
like an amoeba
Bottom of this pot is extremely cold, and the top is also cold. It's just cold everywhere even though. It's unfair. Oh this spots warm
quick reminder
There is a link down in the description to sign up for our self-made training event if you've been wanting to build a career
From making videos at home doing the things that you love this is how you get started